Apple has silently updated their 13 inch
and 15 inch MacBook Pros so let's talk
about everything that's changed along
with what we're really disappointed
about as well as a couple of reasons why
it actually makes sense for someone to
buy one of these new MacBook Pros right
now first of all my condolences to those
who recently bought a 2018 model just to
find out their MacBook is now inferior
make sure to check your return date to
see if you can still return it on the
plus side only a few things have changed
both the 13 inch and 15 inch have
Apple's new fortune butterfly keyboard
showing that the third gen keyboard
still has issues after Apple added the
silicone barrier to protect it from
debris so for those who have been
holding off on a MacBook Pro because of
the failing keyboard it may now actually
be fixed once and for all this almost
seems like an act of desperation by
Apple to release an update with a fixed
keyboard to get people to buy it again
but who knows for the 13-inch MacBook
Pro the only change is a speed increase
on the $1,800 models based processor
from 2.3 gigahertz base clock to 2.4 and
from 3 point 8 gigahertz turbo boost to
4.1 which isn't too big of a change but
you're getting it at the same price as
before the configurable $300 ice 7
upgrade bumps you up from 2.7 gigahertz
base to 2.8 and from 4.5 gigahertz turbo
boost to 4.7 which we don't think is
worth the cash if you're spending that
much just go for the 15-inch model which
includes a dedicated graphics chip in a
newly updated Intel 9th Gen 6 core
processor that gets a much bigger boost
in performance the base CPU goes from 2
points to gigahertz base clock to 2.6
and turbo boost goes from 4.1 gigahertz
to 4.5 now that's a huge difference
considering its price at the same 2400
dollars so for those who waited you're
gonna get a lot more value you can now
upgrade to the first ever 8 core
processor in any MacBook for $300 more
in a contour bow boost up to a massive 5
gigahertz which we think is totally
worth it for anyone who can actually use
those extra cores like for raw video
editing now instead of doing that you
can pay just $100 more for the $2,800
model which comes with a slightly slower
but still 8 core processor the faster
560 X graphics chip in twice the storage
space which
think is worth every penny to be
completely honest we don't think there's
gonna be much of a performance
difference between both of those eight
core processors so just going for the
twenty eight hundred dollar model is the
best value we also highly recommend
upgrading to the Vega 20 graphics chip
if you're doing heavy graphics work or
gaming you can watch this video above to
find out why it's well worth the price
now you might be wondering why the
13-inch MacBook Pro is still stuck on
Intel's 8th gen processor instead of
moving on to nine Chen well taking a
look at Intel's 9 Chen product page it
seems as though none of those processors
come with their premium until iris +
graphics which is a must for 13-inch
models since they lack dedicated
graphics chips other than the processor
and keyboard upgrades literally nothing
else has changed which is the most
disappointing part everyone's been
waiting for a complete redesign with
thinner bezels and we unfortunately have
to wait even longer and if Apple was
planning a redesign for sometime this
year they wouldn't have upgraded the
MacBook Pro right now so it seems like
we're going to be waiting until next
year for a redesign and there's still no
word on the rumored 16 inch MacBook Pro
so there's a chance that that model will
include the new redesign and will come
next year we think it makes more sense
for Apple to redesign the iMac first
starting with the iMac Pro potentially
this year and then redesign the MacBook
Pro afterward one thing that's really
disappointing is that Apple's based
13-inch MacBook Pro for $1,300 is still
a 2017 model with an ancient dual-core 7
gen processor and second generation
butterfly keyboard which is known for
its keyboard issues at that price point
many windows laptop manufacturers have
moved on to four core processors and
some even have dedicated graphics chips
as well so if you're planning to get a
13-inch MacBook Pro we honestly
recommend just paying eighteen hundred
dollars for the 2019 model otherwise
just look elsewhere or by the 2018
MacBook Air instead we've already
ordered a 2019 15-inch MacBook Pro with
a new eight core processor so if you're
not already subscribed click that button
above and make sure to check out some of
our Mac with videos right there
thanks for watching and if you haven't
already smash that like button and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]